la ministre du logement emmanuelle cosse
était à jouy en josas ce mardi 17
janvier la représentante du gouvernement
a signé à cette occasion une convention
d'engagement d'utilité sociale avec
habitat et humanisme une association qui
lutte depuis 30 ans contre le mal
logement et l'insertion des personnes en
difficulté la corse établi sur la
période 2017 2020 c'est un engagement
que le président de la république m'a
demandé de renouveler notamment en mai
dernier en me demandant de réouvrir dans
les 57 mille cinq cents places de
pension de famille qui sont vos loyers
des structures qui sont à cheval entre
eux
on va dire un centre d'hébergement et un
logement pérenne avant cette signature
la ministre a également visité les
locaux de cette maison
intergénérationnelle implantée avenue
jean jaurès cette dernière comprend 48
logements sur deux bâtiments
au total 80 personnes devraient
s'installer dans la structure d'ici fin
février la volonté de la dette du projet
et c'est d'avoir un une mixité il y à
des familles des familles normales landa
si on peut dire il y à des seniors
isolés
il y à des personnes isolées il y a des
moments des familles monoparentales et
des étudiants et des jeunes travailleurs
la maison intergénérationnelle ouvrira
officiellement ses portes le samedi 21
janvier avec cette inauguration
l'association habitat et humanisme
dépassera les deux mille familles logées
depuis sa création